si uno mira la historia de esta isla la
violencia no empieza hoy la violencia
todos los que estudiamos historia muchas
veces nos muestran una cara de punto en
las la historia con tan pobre anna de un
otro otro tipo de haití pero la
violencia que existía antes hace que
nosotros en haití y la cultura
democrática que debería ser sobre todo
por la educación nunca existió salvo
salvo en un tiempo 1860 más o menos
durante el gobierno de jefa durante el
gobierno deje fue más o menos conocimos
una estabilidad donde hay una
continuidad porque por una sencilla
razón la educación la educación por
mabel pero desde un principio si uno
mira la educación en haití cuando de
salir por supuesto tengo todo el respeto
volver salir pero los las únicas 6
well as que existía durante el régimen
de salir estaba dentro de los cantones
militares qué significa esto entiendo
que les alguien quería preservar a los
militares para una posible regreso de
francia pero qué pasa con los demás la
ciudadanía que quería educarse y eso
siempre ha sido así por eso mismo una
cosa que le va a adicionar antes de
terminar
tuvimos que esperar 175 años voy a ser
bien 175 años después de la
independencia para reconocer el rol que
habla mi abuela que habla mis abuelos el
peor como idioma hablado en el país
cuando 90% de la población habla creo
90 por ciento noventa por ciento de
actuación eso todas estas cosas son
indicios que hace que no tenemos la
cultura que no estamos a la altura y
tenemos que de pensar como nación